unter diesem tuch steckt fotografin
sabine alex moderne technik kann sie
nicht begeistern
sie steht auf alte kisten wie diese
großformatkamera mit der sie heute das
panorama einer berliner straße anrichtet
jede aufnahme eine überlegte
entscheidung habe das gefühl dass die
meisten leute eigentlich nur noch durch
ein objektiv ihren urlaub sehen oder ihr
ereignis was sie gerade fotografieren
und seitdem ich das nicht mehr machen
seitdem ich mich bewusst für analog
entschieden habe geht es mir wesentlich
besser also es irgendwie eindruck der so
weg geht
die 31 jährige unterrichtet analoge
fotografie von der aufnahme bis zum
entwickeln der bilder in ihrer werkstatt
am berliner ostkreuz treffen sich jede
woche fans der alten technik
was mir am meisten spaß macht ist die
entschuldigung an der ganzen sache dass
man sich auf das wesentliche
konzentriert das ist halt nicht nur
schnell klick und und dann kann man auch
nicht gleich sehen was wie das ergebnis
ist und das ist ja gerade das spannende
für mich die faszination analoge
fotografie es das ist es fühlt sich
echter dadurch das ist witzig ist also
sich man kann es anfassen es ist nicht
was abstrakt ist das interesse an
analoge fotografie ist so groß dass
sogar neue modelle auf den markt kommen
die reflex von einem londoner startup
ist die erste neue rollfilm kamera seit
25 jahren etablierte hersteller setzen
auf sofortbildkameras ein foto kostet
rund einen euro aufwärts
[Musik]
der bekannteste anbieter polaroid war
schon pleite der pole oscars molo kowski
hat die firma gekauft und 2017 eine neue
kamera herausgebracht die zielgruppe
generation instagram jüngere menschen
reagieren so dass neue teil ist all das
gab es schon mal für sie ist das eine
neue erfahrung sollen foto ist eins der
wenigen interessanten außerhalb des
smartphones passieren das spricht vor
allem junge menschen den technischen
möglichkeiten und wie schnell man die
fotos teilen kann
mehrere ausstellungen widmen sich in
diesem jahr ins den fotos im wiener
westlicht für polaroid project mit
aufnahmen von 300 künstlern darunter
andy warhol die londoner fotograf es
gallery zeigt unveröffentlichte bilder
des deutschen filmemachers wim wenders
er fotografierte seit den 1970 er jahren
so etwas fröhliches unbeschwertes man
hat sie einfache weg gegeben das foto
gehört die mehrwert person auf dem bild
als der dies machte es war einfach teil
des alltags man hat etwas schönes
gemacht dass man teilen konnte der
umgang damit war sehr unbekümmert
kameras machen auch mal probleme
dann hilft foto techniker michael prügel
der berliner hat sich auf das reparieren
analoge kameras spezialisiert unter
seinen kunden viele jüngere menschen die
nur noch mit digitalen bildern
aufgewachsen sind
[Musik]
die kommen aber schon seine uralten box
anja und wollen wissen wie das
funktioniert und damit ein foto machen
und staunen dass es wirklich dann von
vernünftigen dabei raus kommt ja oder
bloß bei digitalen halten nur die clips
wird das liegt in der natur der sache
dass man nur die wichtigen momente
festhält während man mit dem handy sehr
viele fotos macht bei analog geht es mir
darum was man aufnimmt und dabei auch
mal um die ecke zu denken
[Musik]
sabine alex und die anderen sich ihre
aufnahmen anschauen können dauert es
zuerst müssen sie ihre filme mit
chemikalien entwickelt
[Musik]
das tüpfelchen was es halt um perfekt
macht also so ein paar stellen die so
ein bisschen unscharf sind oder doch mal
ein puzzle oder sowas das finde ich
macht eigentlich den reiz aus ob film
oder sofortbildkamera jedes analoge bild
ist eine kleine überraschung
die generation instagram hat ihn fast
schon vergessene zauber des fotos in der
realen welt wieder entdeckt